Well, good morning again, church.
Uh, my name is John, one of the pastors here.
If you are new to our church
or if you've been here a really long time,
we're grateful that you're here.
We love each one of you.
Uh, we're excited to get to worship together today.
Let me invite you to take your copy of God's Word
and turn with me to First Samuel chapter 11,
chapter 11 today as we continue this journey.
Just some housekeeping briefly, as you turn there, remember
that next weekend we will be voting, uh, to affirm
or not those three elder candidates we've been putting
before you for the last couple weeks.
So members, you will get an email on Thursday.
You can vote digitally that way,
or you can wait until next Sunday
and we'll have paper ballots available as well.
So just be praying about that.
Looking forward to next weekend for that.
Today though, we're continuing that journey
through the Old Testament book of one Samuel,
a series we're calling He Shall Reign, uh, which
because it, it's, it's titled that
because it describes Israel's search for an earthly king,
which if you remember, as they did,
that was actually a rejection of their true king,
Yahweh, God almighty.
And what we're learning as we walk through this is
how we can do something very similar in our own hearts.
Even today. Last week Phil showed us out of, uh,
chapters nine and 10, how God appointed Saul
to be Israel's first king
and how God's spirit led that process even
through ordinary means like donkeys, things like that.
Uh, and the narrative Today, what we're beginning to see is
that we're in this transition phase.
I showed this the first week as we kicked this off.
It was Samuel, the, the prophet judge's leadership,
and now we're transitioning
to Saul's leadership of the nation.
His popularity is rising
and Samuel is kind of fading a little bit.
He'll still be involved, but we'll see it a lot
less as we go forward.
But at this point, Saul is effectively the king,
yet there's still a formal coronation ceremony
that will come at the end
of this chapter into the next chapter.
We'll see that over the next couple weeks.
Uh, but we're also gonna see some really early actions
of this man named Saul, some kingship that he shows.
Uh, and I'm gonna read the whole of chapter 11.
First, it's only 15 verses.
We'll set the context with this, then we'll come back
through it as we go.
So first Samuel chapter 11.
Then Ash or ash, the amite went up
and besieged jab Gilead.
And all the men of jab said to Ash, make a treaty
with us will serve you.
But Ash, the Ammonites said to them, on this condition,
I will make a treaty with you
that I gouge out all your right eyes
and thus bring disgrace on all Israel.
And the elders of Jbe said to him, okay,
well give us seven days respite
that we may send messengers throughout all
the territory of Israel.
Then if there is no one to save us,
we will give ourselves up to you.
When the messengers came to GI Gibbon of Saul,
they reported the matter in all the ears of the people,
and all the people wept aloud.
Now behold, Saul was coming from the field behind the oxen,
and, and Saul said, what's wrong
with the people that they're weeping?
And so they told him the news of the men of Jesh
and the spirit of God rushed upon Saul when he heard these
words and his anger was greatly kindled.
He took a yoke of oxen and cut them in pieces
and sent them throughout all the territory of Israel
by the hand of the messengers, saying,
whoever does not come out after Saul
and Samuel, so shall it be done to his oxen.
And the dread of the Lord fell upon the people,
and they came out as one man.
And when he mustered them at bk, the people
of Israel were 300,000 men of Judah, 30,000.
And they said to the messengers who'd come,
thus shall you say to the men of Jes, Gilead, tomorrow,
by the time the sun is hot, you shall have salvation.
When the meers came and told the men of Jes, they were glad.
Therefore, the men of Jabba said, tomorrow,
we will give ourselves up to you.
They're talking to the Ammonite King tomorrow,
we'll give ourselves up to you.
You may do to us, whatever seems good to you.
And the next day, Saul put the people in three companies
that came to the midst of the camp in the morning, watch
and struck down the Ammonites until the heat of the day.
And those who survived were scattered so that no two
of them were left together.
Then the people said to Samuel, who is it that said,
shall Saul reign over us?
Bring them in that we may put them to death.
But Saul said, not a man shall be put
to death this day for today.
The Lord has worked salvation in Israel.
Then Samuel said to the people, come, let us go to Gilgal
and there renew the kingdom.
So all the people went to gal there.
They made Saul King before the Lord in Gilgal.
And there they sacrificed peace offerings before the Lord.
And there Saul and all the men of Israel rejoiced greatly.
So you saw some action, saw some things happen.
And, and here at the beginning of Saul's reign
as Israel's first king, when you look at this,
things appeared pretty promising.
At this point. He just started even not even
fully coordinated yet.
But here at the beginning of his reign, he, he,
things appeared promising.
Now, you might not know like the map
and the lay the land here.
So again, I'll put the map up here
that the Ammonites were an enemy nation on the east
side of the Jordan River.
That's the right side of the map.
And they were going
after this Israelite town that was up by
what you can see Ray moth there.
And this is what was happening for them to, to ask the rest
of Israel to say, Hey guys, we need some help.
So they sent the messenger.
Saul then leads the people, and
and how he did it was he called the nation
to battle alongside him.
And and you saw that they did.
330,000 people showed up to fight with him.
And so this new king leads Israel against the Ammonites.
And as they went out, they routed these people
who were coming against the nation of Israel.
And notice how you see it in verse 13, what Saul said about
how that victory came about.
Verse 13, today,
the Lord Yahweh has worked salvation in Israel.
So at the beginning here, things looked pretty promising
because right here we see it was God
who brought the victory for this new king.
Saul rallies, the troops goes out to battle. What happens?
God brings the victory.
Now, if you know your Bible, you know
that Saul has a pretty bad reputation based on everything.
We'll see from this point forward, the rest of first Samuel,
the rest of sa like we'll know there's a lot about Saul
that the rest of his life shows us.
But notice here that he actually started pretty
well, right?
He started pretty well
and it was God's blessing that showed up here
for his people.
And so there seemed to be this blessing of God,
not only God's blessing,
but you see actually Saul's humility here.
Notice Saul's humility
that he showed great humility in this sequence,
that he brought a military victory for the people.
But, but watch what God had done and how Saul responded.
If you remember back at the end of chapter 10,
there were actually people who opposed Saul being the king.
Like they didn't want him to be the king.
They didn't want anything to do with Saul.
But, but here what happened, God
publicly proved Saul was the king
brought this military victory to show Saul is in charge.
And then verse 12 says this.
Then the people said to Samuel, who is it that said,
shall Saul reign over us?
Like who was the questioning about this?
Bring them in that we may put them to death.
This might have even been something
that the law allowed those who were traitors, those who were
opposing the king.
But they, they basically came to Samuel
and said, Hey, these people oppose Saul.
Saul's clearly the king. Let's execute them.
But watch again, Saul's response, verse 13.
But Saul said, not a man shall be put
to death this day for today.
The Lord has worked salvation in Israel,
like Saul humbly submitted to the Lord alone.
He knew it was God who brought the victory,
and he knew it was God
who would bring vengeance on his enemies if
God wanted that to happen.
So the beginning of Saul's reign sure appeared promising,
didn't, it seemed to be a lot of good.
It seems like the start of something great
that this could be really effective.
Even at the coronation you saw at the end of the chapter,
Saul was leading people to praise God.
Saul was leading people to worship, not not him, God.
He responded with humility. This seems really effective.
Boy, can't we learn from from this today
when you look at the way Saul responded, I mean,
just consider, I I I came across a couple questions
as I was studying this week,
and I thought they're really effective for me.
And I think they'd be helpful for us to just reflect on
and to think about and to consider as we
think about this whole scene.
I mean, just think about this. When good things happen in
our lives, to whom do we give the credit?
When good things happen and all do, do we give credit
where credit is due?
When others praise you for your work,
do you point them to God's grace?
Like when people praise you for what you've accomplished
or what has happened in your life, do you point them
to God's grace or this,
when others want to make much of you?
Do you make much of God?
'cause that's what was happening here, right?
Saul's this new leader and,
and it's, it's good things happening in his life.
Others are praising him and,
and people are wanting to make much of him.
What was he doing? He was pointing back to God.
Do we do the same?
I mean, do you see how those questions would help keep us
humbly focused on the Lord in our lives?
Just some good questions.
But as great as it seemed to be at the start
of Saul's reign,
there were some immediate concerns at the same time.
In fact, it was even just the history of Saul's family
that sparked concerns.
It sparked these questions.
Even just his family line sparked questions
from the beginning, like
Phil talked about last week.
Do you remember what Israelite tribe Saul is from?
He's from the tribe of Benjamin.
Now, there's nothing wrong with being from the tribe
of Benjamin unless you're gonna be the king,
because all the way back in Genesis 49 when Jacob
and his 12 sons, Jacob was dying, Jacob blessed his 12 sons.
He said it was from the tribe of Judah
that the kings would come from.
So even from the beginning, just the differences
of tribes that he's from Benjamin, not from Judah, just,
just the differences of tribes sparked some questions as
to whether Saul is legit or not.
Like, is this the one that God really wants to be the king?
Is this the the long-term solution that God has?
But not only that, not only the differences of tribes here,
notice the allusions to judges in what Saul did here.
I I see it there.
You see it on the notes that judges is
capitalized and that's on purpose.
I'm referring to the actual book of the Bible called judges.
See some allusions to judges in what Saul does.
Look at verses six
and seven here, when, when Saul heard
what the Ammonites were going to do
and wanted to do to his people, look at what Saul does.
This is first Samuel 11 verses six and seven.
And the spirit of God rushed upon Saul when he heard these
words and his anger was greatly kindled.
He took a yoke, or that's two oxen, cut them in pieces,
sent them throughout all the territory of Israel by the hand
of the messenger saying, whoever does not come out
after Saul and Samuel, so shall it be done to his oxen.
Now, that seems a little weird, doesn't it?
You can just imagine you get a box on your front porch
and you open it up and it's raw cube
steak like, what is this?
What, what is happening? Right?
That was sort of what was going on here.
But what really was going on here?
Well, most commentators believe that this was reminiscent
of the events that happened back in Judges 19,
that precipitated the Benjaminite war.
I'm not gonna go into full detail.
We, we walked through judges a couple years ago.
This was a really hard one as we looked at this, but,
but what happened was all the other tribes
of Israel mustard against the Benjamin Knights
because of their horrific sin against a young woman.
And basically the rest of the Israel just wiped out more
or less the tribe of Benjamin, which by the way, led
to the intermarriage between Gibber and Jesh.
Gilead, which is the town
that's in in threatened here in one Samuel.
So there's even this link together.
But, but think of the other parallels here,
because they, they were the Benjamin Knights.
What tribe was saw from, he's from Benjamin.
There was also, again, back in judges 19,
something was cut up
and sent throughout the nation as a call to war.
This is the same thing happening here.
Saul cuts up something, sends it throughout the nation
as a call to action.
But also think about this, judges was right
before the events in one Samuel, at the end
of judges, four times in the last five chapters
of judges, it says this, in those days,
there was no king in Israel.
Everyone did what was right in his own eyes.
That's not a good thing.
Four times it says that
because there was no king in Israel, everyone did
what was right in his own eyes.
Now, the difference here in First Samuel, when Saul does
what he does is that it says explicitly the spirit
of God came on him in leading him to cut up the ox
and send it out.
So that wasn't happening in judges,
they just did it on their own.
So there was a measure of God confirming Saul
that the success
of the military battle was saying Saul
is the leader right now.
That's part of it. But we also can't forget that.
Remember in one Samuel, they had rejected God
as their king in the search for an earthly king.
Not only that in what Saul was doing,
he was acting like one of the judges.
Like he led this whole military campaign,
just like all the judges did in the Old Testament,
in judges, much,
the same language is used in judges about the way those
would would lead and defend.
It was all like the spirit of God rushed upon them,
the spirit of God rushed upon them,
and they defeated the enemy and saved the people.
What happened with Saul? He's acting like a judge.
You put all this together, all these ties back
to the book of judges.
It slants this whole thing.
Saul's doing very negatively
because you remember what it said in judges.
There was no king in Israel. What did they do?
In one Samuel, they rejected God
as their king in search for some other king.
There was no king led to people doing what they wanted here.
Functionally, they were acting like there was no king,
that they were not under the authority of the king.
So here's what the what you wrap all this together,
it shows the problem created
as the people initiated the monarchy here.
They said, we reject God. We want our own king.
They were the ones. Now, God said it was coming,
but it was their initiative instead of God's initiative.
He had the best plans in store.
They went after it this way and that way,
and they looked for the tallest dude.
They got Saul who's not even matching up all the stuff
that needed to be matched
to be the king like, like that.
It's just just instructive for us.
When we start getting ahead of God,
when we start walking our own way with God, what happens?
We get in trouble. It's the same way we see it
happening here.
So it seemed like early on for Saul in this kingship,
it seemed like things were a promising future.
And notice God worked through it.
He still proved he could work through fallen humans
and through a king who submitted to him.
Yes, but there were still all these questions, right?
Too many similarities to judges,
too many things that didn't match.
There were still these questions,
and so what we're coming to at this point, at the end
of chapter 11 is we're still not sure how this is gonna go.
Like we think, okay, God has worked. God set this up.
Maybe it seems like it could be good.
We're not really, we're still not sure how Saul's gonna be.
Seems like he's submitted to the Lord,
but we don't actually know till we get into the next
few chapters.
Will this king, will he remain
submitted to God's word?
Will he remain submitted
to God's prophets like he was supposed to?
We'll find out as we go into the next few weeks.
But ultimately though, and
and this is in the end, this is
what we've already seen in first Samuel A. Little bit.
But here's, this starts to show us very clearly
and very quickly that the story
of Saul's kingship points us forward.
We look at it, we study it, we analyze it,
but ultimately put, it points us forward.
Saul being the king is meant to point us to something else.
Because again, remember how much was wrong with Saul
and his kingship?
How many things were not right?
He wasn't right for the tribe. He acted more like a judge.
It was the people's request to begin with.
It wasn't God's initiative, it was all of that.
It was all primarily to remind us
that there's really only one king
and that king is God almighty.
There's only one king that we truly need.
There's only one king over all the others.
This is what Saul,
as the king is really intended to show us.
It's not about the king here. It's about the one true king.
I love how Psalm 95 puts.
It says, oh, come let us sing to the Lord.
Let us make a joyful noise to the rock of our salvation.
Let us come into his presence with thanksgiving.
Let us make a joyful noise to him with songs
of praise for the Lord.
Yahweh is a great God
and a great king above all Gods.
He is worthy. What that says, he's worthy of all over praise
because he's over all things.
There's one true king.
But do you remember again
how Israel responded to that truth?
Again, it's what we can do just as easily.
Remember, the Lord says to Samuel,
obey the voice of the people and all they say to you,
they've not rejected you.
They have rejected me from being king over them.
That's how we got in this mess with Saul,
with all the ammonite tribe, all the stuff
they've rejected me.
God says, from being king over them, remember that's that.
That word means they spit in his face.
They handled him with contempt.
They said, God, you're not our king at all.
God was their king.
He was the one to protect them, preserve them,
prosper them, fulfill them.
They just started looking everywhere else for it.
Man, we do the same thing.
Some people look outside of God's boundaries
for sexual fulfillment.
Some people look to false religions for inner peace.
Some people look to radical weight loss schemes in order
to be socially acceptable.
Some people look to guns
and ammunition as the protection that they
absolutely must have to feel safe.
Now, those
and so much more can be the kings
that we look to in our lives for protection
and provision and fulfillment.
The problem is if we allow those things
to call the shots in our lives, that's
what the Bible calls an idol, that it sits on the throne.
It is our king.
If it's, if it's what we put our trust in,
it is an idol in our lives.
Again, we can't knock God off of his throne.
He is the rightful king over all things.
But we can act as if we are the king of our own lives
or as if this or that will give us what we're looking for.
And in so doing, we do exactly what one Samuel eight,
seven says, they have rejected me from being king over them.
We do the exact same thing. We forsake God.
There's only one king,
and we must keep him at the throne of our own hearts.
But the story of Saul's kingship not only points us forward
to the fact that there's one true king,
it also points us forward another way
that there's only one savior as well, that
there's only one savior.
'cause really, when you look at one Samuel 11,
it's a salvation narrative, isn't it?
This whole chapter, you look at it, the town is in trouble,
and so verse three, they look for someone,
it says to save them.
Then verse nine, what does Saul talk about?
He talks about this, this word of salvation that he sends
to the people even himself.
In verse 13, what does he say?
The Lord has worked salvation in Israel today.
So we've seen this already throughout the book.
You can trace back all the way to Genesis,
but it's all the way throughout one Samuel as well,
that the Lord himself can handle delivering his people.
He doesn't need us like his system works.
He can deliver. He will deliver.
No earthly king is actually needed here.
You remember how that worked a couple chapters ago?
God just won it without anybody. God won it without anybody.
God won it without anybody.
He does it even here a little bit, right?
There's nothing else is needed. We just need him.
Now, God may choose to work through his servants as he does
with Saul, but only God alone offers salvation
for his people.
Like just here. Just look at this example.
God provided the leader, God empowered the leader,
and God defeated the enemy.
It's very clear God brings the victory.
He is the savior. See, that
Could, There actually may be another
layer to this cake.
Could have put an onion up there, right?
But I picked cake cake's better.
See there, there's a deeper layer here
that actually takes our minds to a greater victory,
to the greatest victory,
and it's something we would easily miss
because we speak English,
And it has to do with the name of the ammonite king here,
who's coming against God's People.
See, when you read through the Bible in the Old Testament,
you see all these military victories
and battles of people coming against God's people.
The Bible doesn't always, in fact,
doesn't often record the name
of the enemy king who's coming against God's people.
It might just say King of Moab
or king of Amina, like whatever.
It doesn't often here. It repeats it a number of times.
Did you see it? I believe
that was intentional because what does verse one say
that the Ammonite king's name was?
It says, Ash is the way you would say that in Hebrew,
and that word in Hebrew, by the way, means snake.
Okay? Where am I going with this?
So when an ancient Israelite would read one Samuel 11,
what they would read is that the snake went up
to besiege, jesh, Gilead,
and where their minds would go most likely is
to Genesis chapter three, where in verse one
of Genesis three, it says, Ash,
the serpent was more crafty than all the other beasts
of the field that the Lord God had made.
And so what you had back in Genesis three was an adversary
attacking Adam and Eve,
and as they were defeated, they were disgraced
and became his slaves.
Yet what did God do? He intervened
and declared war on Ash saying this in Genesis three 15
where he promises a savior.
Listen to what it says.
I will put enmity between you, Ash
and the woman between your offspring and her offspring.
He shall bruise your head and you shall bruise his heel.
What happened in one Samuel 11 Nahash?
The ammonite tried verse two,
to bring disgrace on all Israel
by attacking God's people and what did he want to do?
Enslaved them. Yet what did God do?
He intervened
and declared war on nahash by anointing Saul
to be a savior, to crush the head of that snake.
Do you see what's happening here?
God allowed the ammonite threat to come against Israel so
that he could confirm Saul as his king,
as Saul defeated the snake
that his people needed him to defeat.
See how this is all working out?
Sounds familiar now, doesn't it?
Because where do our minds go when we hear the word snake?
Our minds go to the enemy of our souls, Satan,
whose desire is to disgrace and enslave people,
but that war is not just a war for a town or for land.
That war is against our souls to destroy us
and praise God that he intervened
and sent a savior,
the only savior, right?
We're talking about this, the only savior king Jesus.
Now, watch how he does it.
Watch how he did this, that yes, Genesis three says
that snake would inflict a wound on him through the cross.
Jesus would ultimately crush Satan's head.
The power of sin would be defeated
through Jesus's death on the cross and the power of death,
and Satan would be defeated
through his victorious resurrection.
Out of that grave,
there's only one savior church, right?
That's how the same kind of process
of redemptive history we read in Genesis one, Samuel,
we see it in Jesus, the ultimate only
Savior, okay?
And the fact that there is only one savior church means
something very clear for us.
Let's stop looking for functional saviors then.
If there's only one, then let's stop looking
for functional saviors.
We saw how we look for replacement kings to protect us,
to provide for us the same way we look for functional
saviors, to deliver us from the mess
that we are in in our lives.
We look for politicians to fix our nation.
We look for a relationship to complete us.
We look for money to finally get us
where we think we should be.
We look for entertainment to help us escape from reality.
Those are all ways that we try to,
to be saved from something
and hear me, even religion
and church can be functional saviors,
because what actually saves you is not the rituals
and behaviors associated with Christianity.
It's not you being a better person than your coworker
or your classmate.
It's not the fact that you grew up in church
or that you know a lot of answers in your small group.
The only way you are saved is through
what Jesus has done for you.
It's not about the rich.
It's not about just being calling yourself a Christian.
It's Jesus' work in your place that actually saves you.
It's you turning from your sin and yourself
and saying, Jesus, I trust you
and your work that you did for me.
I trust you in it. I place my faith in your life, death
and resurrection that all of you,
what you've done counts for me.
It counts in my place. You are my savior.
There's only one savior.
So stop looking for functional saviors
And listen, if you've never responded to Jesus like
that, why not today?
If you've been trusting in any
of those other things, why not today?
Say, Jesus, I've been trying
so long, I've been trying too hard.
I've been exhausting myself to try
to act like a Christian when I've never actually
trusted you for salvation.
Why not today? But listen, if you have,
if you have trusted
and placed your faith in Jesus already,
should this not draw us nearer,
should this not cause us to examine our hearts
and look deeply within us to search our hearts?
Say, Jesus, what more do you want from me?
What more of me do you want as my king, as my savior?
And should this not spark worship
and obedience as we consider this king
and savior, that's our our Lord?
Like Psalm 95 said, the Lord is worthy
of our praise because he's the great king over all
other gods.
He is the humble savior.
So let's respond to him in that church,
in faith, in hope and obedience and in trust.
He's all I need. Bow your heads with me.
Let's take this to the Lord together, if you would.
Lord, I pray right now for every person, as we do,
let this word sit on our hearts, that you would
dig deeply into us right now,
and we'd give you some space right now in our hearts,
whether we do that regularly
or not, God, this is an opportunity.
So I pray as we just sit here quietly for a moment,
you would reveal to us where we have placed other kings,
other saviors in our lives, trusted those instead
of you and lead us back.
Draw us back to you. God,
just ask yourself those questions that I asked earlier about
where you point others,
when good things happen in your life,
who do you give the credit to
when others wanna make much of you?
Do you make much of God?
Maybe that's just a little symptom of something deeper,
run to the Lord in repentance and obedience,
because remember the point of life,
the reason God created you.
The reason he created me is to make much of Him,
to glorify him, celebrate him
so that all would see and know who he is.
If there's any sliver, just like in my life, the slivers
of things that I still love too much,
I still love more than him, I still give credence to
and trust in more than him.
Ask him to rip that out.
Continually remove those things so that he can be
shining bright through you.
Let's start by singing together this way.
So if you're able, let's stand together
and worship him in response.